sammarinese benvenuto il nuovissimo beta
ebbene si ragazzi siamo agli sgoccioli
perché tra pochissime ore inizierà
ufficialmente la maturità 2018 maturandi
di tutto il mondo vi siamo vicini
visto come avete riempito di domande
sulla mia maturità ho deciso di fare un
bel video dove proverò a raccontarvi i
momenti top e i momenti flop sicuramente
sono stati più i flop della mia maturità
inutile prendervi in giro e dire che non
studiavo che non andava bene a scuola
perché soprattutto al liceo ero
abbastanza secchiona e non avevo un
bellissimo rapporto con il resto della
classe per vari motivi
un giorno magari vi racconterò il mio
percorso scolastico e quindi diciamo che
mi isolavo nello studio mi piaceva
studiare per prendere dei bei voti e per
insomma togliermi qualche soddisfazione
per la mia maturità ha iniziato con un
momento top cioè sono riuscita ad
arrivare prima insomma dell'esame di
stato con il massimo dei con il
punteggio massimo di crediti diciamo che
si poteva ottenere prima di fare l'esame
quindi ero contentissima era già era già
un ero già un pelino più tranquilla
iniziano gli esami quindi si parte
subito con la prima prova io ero
abbastanza tranquilla perché adoravo
scrivere tuttora mi piace molto scrivere
una delle mie materie preferite era
appunto la letteratura italiana quindi
già avevo una mezza idea di scegliere
insomma quella tipologia in tracia
arrivò il giorno dell'esame
leggo la prima traccia e non leggo
neanche le altre perché era capitato il
tema la traccia su la coscienza di zeno
che era uno
una delle opere che io avevo preferito
in assoluto quindi non so se mai
successa una cosa del genere non so
neanche non avevo neanche idea di cosa
fossero le altre tracce perché ho letto
la prima e bruce sono partita non me ne
fregava niente delle altre tracce
qui di una gioia momento top direi
scrivo forse venti fogli faccio vari
collegamenti non me li ricordo tutti
però sicuramente ne ho fatto uno col
rosso malpelo il secondo giorno seconda
prova
io frequentavo il liceo linguistico
scusa come l'avevo ancora detto e quindi
c'era la lingua straniera che per me era
lo spagnolo tra parentesi non so se lo
sapete ma mio papà e spagnolo quindi
diciamo che era abbastanza pura
passeggiatina per me è infatti anche gli
è andata molto bene quindi due momenti
supertop adesso arriva il mondo il
momento super flop la sera prima della
terza prova
veroli che studiavo che ripassavo presa
dall'ansia della terza prova che era lo
scritto che chiaramente mi faceva più
paura
il mio fidanzato decide bene di
lasciarmi che cari ma che carino che
gesto dolce vi rendete conto di cosa
vuol dire per una diciassettenne
diciottenne mi ricordo essere lasciata
il giorno prima della terza prova
non me l'aspettavo è potevi lasciarmi
fino alla maturità o no
potevi fare questo sforzo secondo me la
terza prova nonostante tutto va da dio
se non ricordo male il punteggio erano
prima prova 15 14 seconda prova e 15
terza prova
quindi dopo questo momento super flop
io comunque arrivavo all'orale con se
non sbaglio un punteggio altissimo
quindi mi era stato detto se in caso tu
facessi scena muta all'orale tu comunque
passeresti l'esame quindi io ero
definitivamente tranquilla non che
volessi fare scena muta però comunque ti
rilassi un attimo se dicono cosa del
genere
l'orale però è stato nuovamente un
momento abbastanza flop perché non mi
ero malata per tutto l'inverno ragazzi e
rossana come un pesce due giorni o tre
giorni prima temi orale mi viene la
bronchite ragazzi incredibile
incredibile quindi immaginate la mia
poca voglia di affrontare l'orale perché
comunque era in condizioni fisiche
tremende stavo davvero male cioè proprio
fisicamente e quindi aggiungici
l'agitazione il ripassare tutto la sera
prima per paura di dimenticarsi ma cosa
insomma ero nel panico più totale
ragazzi allora era più di un anno che mi
facevo i viaggi e pensavo al mio outfit
per l'orale
in tutto questo panico generale
non ci ho neanche pensato mi sono messa
di giuro la prima cosa che ho trovato
c'è un jeans una maglietta e un paio di
scarpe da ginnastica perché ero
veramente distrutta dalla vita entro lì
dentro
saluto tutti è la prima cosa ti dico e
vi chiedo scusa
ho appena perché era vero mi ha appena
calato l'antibiotico nella sala vicino
ho appena preso l'ennesimo antibiotico
sto male se mi capita di succhiarmi il
naso vi chiedo scusa ma non so come fare
quindi immaginate che bella passato
insomma il panico iniziale
io avevo la mia tesina che adesso
brevemente vi descriverò anche perché
non me la ricordo benissimo in tutte le
sfaccettature le materie il titolo era
caos e ordine
chiaramente non mi ricordo esattamente
cosa portavo di ogni materia mi ricordo
di astronomia che portavo le
costellazioni le stelle eccetera
eccetera di inglese creatura inglese e
non mi ricordo più niente di storia
portavo il fascismo nazismo e pirandello
italiano portavo pirandello e mi ricordo
più ragazzi ma non è di memoria inizia a
parlare della tesina inizio rispondere
alle varie domande va abbastanza bene e
con mio grande stupore passa velocemente
cioè io mi immaginavo di stare lì le ore
forse sono stata lì effettivamente
un'ora ma il tempo vola vacher avevo
così voglia di finirla ta che in uno
schiocco di dita
io ho finito l'esame e mi ricordo la
classica domanda preparato
che cos'ha intenzione di fare il
prossimo anno
preparatevi perché io ho detto una
cazzata perché non ve la ero preparata e
quindi visto che avevo le idee veramente
confusissima ho detto economia che non
l'avrei mai fatta farò lì per lì non sa
poco della economia perché comunque mi
interessa molto
insomma quell'ambito non vorrei
proseguire gli studi di quel settore
quando allora tantissimi di voi mi hanno
fatto questa domanda e cioè come ci si
sente ragazzi ci si sente leggeri
leggeri leggeri e una sensazione
bellissima che non dimenticherò mai
mi ricordo quel momento in cui sono
uscita dalla scuola e sentivo i piedi
leggerissimi mi sembrava quasi di volare
da quanto peso mi ero tolto finalmente
perché comunque già dall'inizio
dell'anno 1 all ansia per l'esame ma non
mi aspettavo il voto che poi alla fine
ho preso non me lo aspettavo perché
comunque
cioè nonostante mi fossi davvero
impegnate eccetera eccetera mi sembrava
una cosa allucinante prendere quel voto
cioè veramente lontana da me
eppure ragazzi vi devo confessare che
sono uscita con 100 e che è stata una
soddisfazione enorme che non serve a
niente uscire con 100 alla maturità
perchè alla fine non mi è servito a
nulla anche all'università non serve è
però è proprio una soddisfazione
personale e non dire ho concluso questo
percorso con il massimo dei voti quindi
sicuramente quando ho letto quel numero
sul cartellone è stata una gioia immensa
però non ne nondimento insomma non serve
a nulla se prendi centesimi di 90 1080
l'importante è essere soddisfatti del
proprio percorso passare chiaramente
l'esame e godersi quel momento perché ve
lo ricorderete per tutta la vita non vi
ricorderete il vuoto ma vi ricorderete
la sensazione è l'emozione di della fine
di quel percorso
godetevi davvero questa maturità non so
che avete l'ansia e è normalissimo però
godetevi questi ultimi attimi di liceo
perché vi assicuro che vi mancheranno e
non per il compagno per la situazione
proprio per la spensieratezza perché
fidatevi che poi dopo il liceo
all'università o lavoro qualsiasi strada
intraprendente non troverete mai quella
sensazione di leggerezza e
spensieratezza che avete adesso io vi
faccio un grandissimo in bocca al lupo e
mi auguro che vada tutto per il meglio
fatemi sapere mi raccomando tenete mia
giornata come una sorella maggiore
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto e
che abbia fatto sorridere ma anche
riflettere pensare a questo bellissimo
momento che state attraversando
vi mando un bacione norme vi abbraccio
fortissimo ci vediamo al prossimo video
in bocca al lupo ragazzi